because we're not doing pcrs
we do not have a really good handle on
the amount of re-infection but experts
suspect reinfection is happening given
that 81 percent of canadians are double
vaxxed against covid yet we're still
seeing a six wave after all it's not an
impossible scenario says the medical
director of the vancouver infectious
diseases center it is possible to
develop
covet
after having recovered from it fairly
recently as recent as three months says
infectious disease dr gerald evans
though it seems one sneaky variant has
disturbed the status quo before omicron
came along we did not see people getting
any kind of re-infection until about 90
days had passed with omicron that
interval seems to be a little bit
shorter it's about 60 days it's still a
rare occurrence and it depends on three
factors immunologist ali abdel setter
says your age vaccination status and
your immune response dictate reinfection
if you're a younger individual fully
vaxxed and got a severe response to your
first infection you may get a hybrid
immunity lasting almost six to eight
months bottom line immunity from a
vaccine is always better that concept
that natural immunity is better is
completely wrong
as if it wasn't already complicated
abductor says the variant you caught may
also affect reinfection recent surges in
the uk and denmark suggest those
infected with delta likely develop
immunity from all other previous
variants but an omicron infection with
its very different makeup will likely
only protect you against another omicron
yet may leave you vulnerable to all the
other variants
the risk of covid19 reinfection in
children now also in the forefront as
quebec sees worrying pediatric
hospitalizations last week 24 000
children in schools across quebec were
out because of cohoot that's a lot of
children all the more reason to get
those above the age of five vaccinated
and a strong indication for the need for
boosters as for how long you should wait
to top up your dose after recovering
from kovid nasi puts that number at four
to eight weeks
nudibrane global news